hi i'm beryl and once again i'm a guest
on buzzfeed's channel
hello the theme today is unique food
combinations this is something that i
have actually done over on my channel
twice before okay now hold on
i'm into this i'm actually pretty into
this i ask people in my community
what are the unique combinations that
actually really work together
and i will try them to be honest i am
somebody who has a very
forgiving palette
i like it oh that's good this is
incredible
oh my god i pretty much like everything
maybe to a fault today i have two people
from my community who are sharing
their unique combinations hi there my
name is sam hi
my name is lily one is from the uk and
another is from the usa
so let's try them boom
hi there my name is sam and i come from
market england and the combo that i want
to share with you today
is golden syrup and cheddar cheese
sandwiches
this combo comes from my childhood i was
about 11.
my dad's a bit of a practical joker he
came out with these cheese sandwiches
and he said oh sam sam i dare you to try
this i dare you to try this you'd always
do this kind of stuff with
weird types of food but for some reason
this time
it really worked it was really good
when i tell people about this they are
very weirded out because here in the uk
uh the golden syrup
that you use is used mostly for
either porridge or for desserts but
you know i have a motto your weird is
someone else's normal
i think like mixing things together
constantly
always comes out with the best combos i
think it works
really well and you'll never know unless
you try it
okay this first one is the golden syrup
and cheddar cheese combo
to be honest i've never had golden syrup
before
[Music]
hmm
i went through a lot of emotions there i
will just say this off the bat
cheese and desserts is something that i
do have a little bit of experience with
and i know that it works so the idea of
pairing cheese
and this golden syrup for me i was like
i know where we're going
somebody submitted this to me originally
from the philippines where it was
condensed milk and cheese on toast and
since then i've had it
honestly numerous times savory and sweet
is a really really good combo and the
fat from cheese just pairs
really well with sugary things hey
new york city
[Music]
yes it's good
hi my name is lily i live in austin
texas
and i am going to talk to y'all about
my grandma's recipe for apple and white
cheddar pie
baking on the holidays is something that
i always really liked to do with my
family
especially my grandma this is a recipe
that i learned from her
way back in the day when i was a kid we
did a lot of
experimenting with baking and trying
weird combos
and whenever i make this recipe it just
really makes me think of spending
holidays with her it's kind
of bittersweet to think about because
you know we haven't been able to spend
holidays
together this year at first
a lot of people might think that it
doesn't make a lot of sense as a
combination
but honestly it really does
i mean you've got crust so you've got a
bread
you've got cheese you've got fruit it's
basically a sweet charcuterie board
once you eat it it's it's not even
really a thought
of does this work it's more just
this is a really good pie
i think that everyone should try this
recipe the addition of cheese
is such a good way to make something as
classic as an apple pie just
go up a level it's really good
and it makes me think of my family
okay apple and cheddar pie and honestly
like it does make sense i feel like i
didn't mean to make
this like cheese episode but that's kind
of what it is
[Music]
oh my god lily's right this takes apple
pie
and just like elevates it
[Music]
so interestingly enough a lot of people
responded
with this comment um and i did a little
bit of research
and i've definitely seen iterations of
this around paul hollywood from great
british bake off even talked about it
there's a saying in yorkshire that apple
pie without cheese it's like a kiss
without a squeeze
oh paul
yum i haven't had apple pie though and i
don't even know how long
i was actually pretty surprised that i
made this myself a part of me was like
i'm just gonna buy apple pie
slop some cheese on top bob's your uncle
but i want the extra mile you know
and it was worth it i think my main
takeaway from this episode
and you know also having done this
before and learning
through it is that food is meant to be
experimented with and all of these rules
that we have about
what does and doesn't go together
it's kind of silly and we should try
things and you know maybe they'll work
and maybe they won't work either way
that's okay but experimentation is part
of the fun
maybe you'll give these a try and you'll
like them maybe not
either way i hope that you guys like the
video and i will see you all
later
you